good morning believe nation today's
message is share the credit over to you
Michael Bloomberg you never wanted to
beat your competition no I want to be
successful you said teammates versus
competition right yeah man but but I
mean I'd Salomon Brothers all those
times I you work with other people one
of the ways incidentally Stephanie to
really get ahead is to give credit to
somebody else when I say oh I didn't do
it Lloyd did that and he involved me let
me tell you I'm telling everybody it's
me as well but I've now made a friend
and you respect me because I've shared
the credit and if you say no me me me
III nobody likes you and nobody respects
you and they think you are exaggerating
everything but to the extent you give
credit to else was the thought of alot
are they exaggerating doesn't even come
up I really love this message because i
think as entrepreneurs we're offering on
the front lines right we're offering
doing the glorious glamorous part of the
business right we do a lot of the crap
stuff as well right we do a lot of the
behind the scenes you know 1800 hour
workweek stop that nobody sees but we
also get to do the the frontline sup the
glamorous stuff the stuff that gets
attention right we're the ones who are
in the media we're the ones getting the
praise from the customers you know the
best part of my day is waking up and
doing the youtube comments and seeing
the praise that comes from you guys on
the videos it makes me feel good it
makes me feel like what I'm doing is
important I think a challenging and
building a team is that your team
doesn't always get to see that stuff
right the programmer was working on your
website does he get to see that material
that's coming out you know the people
who are engineering your product do they
get to see the results from the
customers often it's a no so there's a
su G disconnect and when people can feel
like the work that they're doing is
important and valuable and is helping
improve people's lives then they're much
more connected to your business and I've
always tried to be conscious of
involving my entire team in the things
that I'm doing and let them know that
their work
adds value and has meaning one of the
things that I do is every Friday I look
through some of the more special
comments that have come in from the
YouTube channel ones that somebody
chairs just a life changing story about
how our videos are really helping them
through some really tough moment in
their life how it helped them believe in
themselves how helped to launch
something amazing or could be somebody
actually thinking the team and saying
hey I want to thank you and your team
for all these videos that you're making
I find one comment every week and then I
scheduled to go out to my team on monday
so they start their day with a warm
comment coming from the team and I think
it's great because a lot of the people
who may have worked in other jobs before
they've never seen that kind of
recognition or praise or awareness and
they feel like they're disconnected from
what the mission of the business is
because we're just focused so much on
the code or the backend processes and so
I think it's super important to share
the credit involve your team let them
know what they're doing is important and
it not only makes them feel good and
value and a part of the team I think it
makes you feel good to look I love
sharing stuff with my team let me know
that they contribute it to something
really meaningful and important so the
question of the day today is how do you
share the credit or do you share the
credit leave it in the comments below
I'm going to join in the discussion
thank you guys so much for watching have
an amazing day continue to believe and
i'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events best
go